la alfombra roja de cannes está llena de
estrellas y al margen los que esperan
estar un día frente a las luces la joven
directora magda link unif es una de esas
decididas aspirantes a sus 18 años
asiste a su primer festival de cannes y
por fin la joven cineasta consigue pisar
su primera alfombra roja
siempre me ha interesado el cine y aquí
no hay palabras que sean
es sencillamente asombroso
[Risas]
unifican un concurso para jóvenes
cineastas de 14 a 22 años los 25
candidatos ganadores fueron invitados a
kan tras filmar un vídeo de un minuto y
30 segundos sobre el tema de algo que
les inspira banif eligió filmar su
relación de amor-odio con su ciudad
natal y nantes
en conclusión si hago este vídeo es
porque desde el fondo de mi corazón me
gustaría poder decir una vez mi
ayuntamiento me inspira
y escribí mi guión por la noche y al día
siguiente hice mi voz en un estudio y el
fin de semana rodamos la película y eso
fue todo luego enviamos el vídeo el
concurso llamado mote a coloco los
carteles de los 25 ganadores en la
estación de tren de khan incluyendo el
de bonis
es iluminar nuestro barrio el de todos
el de la gente con talento creo que es
el comienzo de lo que quiero hacer
como muchos jóvenes cineastas banif
espera tener algún día una película en
la carrera del palais de festival sede
de uno de los festivales de cine más
prestigiosos del mundo la ceremonia de
este año terminará el 28 de mayo